tu mets moi m vous êtes le seul à m'être
oui oui je dirais même c'est pas la
france était assis je pense qu'elle est
très raciste je pense que ces derniers
deux choses la première peut-être de
manquer un peu de respect aux gens qui
vont venir témoigner nous raconter des
histoires que subissent tous les jours
mais qu'on va exposer une fois sur un
plateau de télé peut-être dont on n'a
plus jamais entendu parler et puis les
chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes on a des
exemples tous les jours des histoires on
l'a tous plus incroyables les unes que
les autres
j'ai mon beau frère saïd il vous
ressemble un petit peu cirilli les maths
brun un peu cheap est plutôt beau gosse
bon ben si vous n'étiez pas vous n'étiez
pas au bout et il s'est mis à courir par
exemple pour attraper le tramway est là
une brigade de la bac l'interpellent le
bloc est lui nommé pourquoi est-ce que
tu cours tu y mets jeu courtes pour
attraper le tramway il en veut du coup
contrôle d'identité c'est pas très grave
hélène bière installez-vous dans les
aéroports à la douane souvent parce que
lorsque j'arrive à charles de gaulle la
poussette arrivant dernier
du coup on doit attendre très longtemps
et je regarde ce qui se passe regardez
qui est toujours interpellé c'est pas
une victimisation mais c'est toujours
les mêmes personnes que les données vont
interpeller vous allez me dire si vous
n'avez rien à vous reprocher faites vous
contrôlez et je suis assez d'accord mais
on le voit si dans le logement
rappelez vous cette histoire où on avait
dit que le propriétaire ne voulait pas
de noir ça avait fait une grande affaire
sauf qu'en réalité c'est le quotidien
même chose alors le logement
justement je vous montrais justement
cette caméra cachée puisque on a et nous
sommes on a envoyé un membre de notre
équipe en caméra cachée dans une agence
immobilière en région parisienne se
faisant passer pour un propriétaire
voulant louer son bien
ayant des demandes très spécifique sur
l'origine des futurs locataires alors
joly on a fait plusieurs donc y en a
plein qui ont bien réagi
forcément voilà on va on n'allait pas
les montrer ce soir mais il ya eu bien
sûr des dérives et c'est ce qu'on va
vous montrer
regardez
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est vite en seizièmes
d'appartements en scène un coup sur sa
partenaire achetés au restaurant les
enfants il vous fera le 10 juin 10 15
ans elle croit qu'il va faire sur la
mise à jour de celui-ci s'est clos sur
le péroné val andré miquel à ses tounes
épidémie disney sont assez riches je
suivrai faire en ne lisant pas dormi et
les amis qui sont venus vers nous et tu
me racontes gaza sans méchanceté le
cugnalais d'élevage sont assez lâches et
des gens comment voter
voilà donc ça non mais ça existe bien
sûr times est d'accord oui voilà quand
je vois que c'est pas bien sûr ça existe
un joli on en a on est allé dans une
autre agence immobilière donc je vous
lis le ratio c'est une sur deux voilà on
va pas se mentir
voilà c'est une sur deux il y en a une
qui réagit bien une autre on a pu le
voir la regarde et on a fait le même
test regarde oui
retrouvez nos créateurs chien on a des
voisins rattachement des lieux de débat
[Musique]
voilà alors c'est vous dis je voyais lna
messieurs voilà franchement inadmissible
c'est ce que nous dit myriam tibi voilà
choix les choix les réactions de tous
autour du plateau même dans le public
je vais vous montrer une autre caméra
cachée qu'on a fait c'est un candidat
avec un nom à consonance maghrébine qui
a 37 % de chances de moins en moins de
trouver un logement lorsqu'ils
recherchent mal alors on a voulu
vérifier mener les enquêtes en appelant
des annonces et en appelant avec deux
identités différentes
regardez et sachez que sur 60 appels 18
ont eu cette réaction
voilà donc c'est à peu près une sur
trois regarde bonjour je suis moi m 24
ans je vous appelle concernant une
annonce pour le studio arras d'accord ok
a cédé à louer un mince depuis longtemps
ok bon bah écoutez le temps là merci
beaucoup
oui bonsoir monsieur je m'excuse de vous
déranger je m'appelle edward garnier et
je me permets de vous contacter au sujet
d'un appartement je voulais savoir s'il
était toujours disponible
est ce qu'il est possible d'aller le
visiter au niveau de la fréquentation
c'est
c'est vrai c'est bien fréquenté
franchement c'est pas du peuple qu
sociaux s'ils sont d'accord voilà c'est
majoritairement français quoi on peut on
peut se dire d'accord très bien parfait
merci beaucoup au revoir bonjour ce
prime à 13 ans je m'appelle mohamed
benkaddour je vous appelle concernant l'
annonce pour le la pour la deuxième fois
a priori c'est pas possible de le
visiter alors à gauche mais pas de
problème je vous dérange pas plus alors
merci mme thomas oui et non je m'appelle
edouard dernier et je me suis permis de
vous contacter car j'aime voir votre
annonce sur le bon coin pour un
appartement t2 je voulais savoir déjà
dans un premier temps si toutefois il
était toujours disponible
est ce qu'il est possible de venir le
visiter du coup je trouve aujourd'hui ce
serait parfait merci beaucoup au revoir
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle mohamed benkaddour
je vous contacte concernant l'annoncé
pour le t2 au je voulais savoir s'il
n'était encore disponible
vous proposez
je peux pas le visiter samedi fois c'est
toujours d'accord donc vous pour
l'instant pas possible de le visiter en
tout cas attendre vos nouvelles vendredi
quoi merci
alors bonjour madame je m'excuse de vous
déranger je m'appelle edward garnier et
je me permets de vous contacter au sujet
d'une annonce pour un appartement t2 je
voulais savoir s'il était toujours
disponible
super est ce qu'il est possible de venir
le visiter
d'accord très bien et ben écoutez moi je
suis disponible samedi matin donc ça
serait avec plaisir au niveau du du
quartier de fins de l'immeuble plus tôt
c'est un immeuble s'est désolé demandé
ça qui est plutôt plutôt bien bien
fréquentée alors je vous le dis il ya
énormément de réactions à la sur les
rideaux je vous dis ça a été réalisée au
trucage
alors bien sûr je vous dis sur 60 appels
18 ont eu cette réaction bien sûr grave
au prix c'est que c'est une sur trois
donc c'est quand même et non voilà et on
a fait 60 appelle donc voilà il y en a
40 de curieux pas la même réaction qui
ont donné voilà mais quand même une
surcroît c'est incroyable surtout quand
on rigole mais mettez-vous à la place de
ces personnes mon frère il s'appelle le
docteur mohamed il est interne et il
cherchait un appartement sur l'île donc
il est vain salaires qui permettait de
louer un appartement gt sont garants
donc un garant qui avait des revenus
conséquents et malgré tout il a dû
passer de plus de quarante appels avant
d'avoir ne serait-ce qu'une réponse
positive et le exactement ce qui s'est
passé dans le magnéto c'est à dire que
il présent sa situation sans dire son
nom et son prénom
oubliez tout va bien vous avez un
salaire convenable un garant une
perspective d'avenir car il est médecin
et lorsqu'il annonce son nom lui dit ah
bah nan l'appartement est loué sauf que
là on rigole c'est un pan un problème
dans la société sauf que si vous
rajoutez au logement le problème d'accès
au travail le gouvernement avait lancé
un testing dont on attendait aussi les
résultats notamment sur les entreprises
qui ne seraient pas vertueuse et qui ne
pratiquerait la discrimination une forme
de racisme
rajoutez à ça le fait ce qui se passe
avec la police rajoutez à ça aussi ce
qui se passe à peu dans les médias dans
les écoles de journalisme
ouais je suppose qu'ils aient des gens
d'amis issus des minorités qui sont
présents regardez ce qui se passe sur
les plateaux télé ban ans tombe pas fait
peut-être exception dans ce qui se passe
je suis désolé au monde politique c'est
exactement la même chose et qu'est ce
qui se passe une fois que
systématiquement on rejette ces
personnes là comme différente des autres
et finalement ne pouvons pas accéder
un niveau supérieur de la société car
quand il s'agit de faire hubert hits
daily verrou de garder les enfants de
travailler dans les plonge dans les
restaurants n'y a pas de problème les
immigrés les étrangers on en veut dès
qu'on veut être un peu de gras d un peu
ce qui se passe parce qu'on a fait des
études on veut faire un peu mieux et
bien là on nous rejette et qu'est ce qui
se passe quand on est rejeté et ben on
se replie et qu'est ce qu'est ce qui se
passe on est entre nous et quand on
reste entre nous ont dit vous êtes des
communautaristes vous êtes communautaire
vous ne voulez pas vous intégrer à la
france donc on exclut deux fois la
société
la première par la france et puis la
deuxième par une autre élite qui
considère que l'on fait on n'a pas de
place